when our next guest was born the Midwife
declared one day she would be famous and
guess what it came true please welcome
the exceptionally talented beautiful and
magnanimous Naomi Watts
[Applause]
what a wild prediction that the Midwife
like said one day I mean that's the
story my mom tells me and
yeah who knows I don't know well got a
big imagination too so maybe she or
maybe it was just one of those Witchy
Poo moments where the woman knew that
you would one day become like maybe she
said it to every mom though
I doubt well you never know we'll have
to find her and you know now your mom
was a model and your dad was a sound
engineer for Pink Floyd yes yes well my
mom I know yeah it's kind of a big deal
yeah
and is it true that like when you were
younger you kind of wish your parents
were less cool oh yeah yeah
um I wished
um my mom would turn up to school in
like a three-piece suit and you know be
wearing some I don't know nylon threads
they were just never those people
um my mom wore like leather boots
platform you know leather pants hair you
know be rocking her way in I'd be choose
mom
I I longed for normal you know straight
parents you know they were not that okay
so you are like a word accoladed like
one of the most important esteemed
prestigious actresses on the planet and
I know that you can do many many accents
okay and many dialects you've conquered
them all but is it true that Irish is
something that maybe you haven't yet or
you want to do I would like to I would
love to play an Irish girl and it's sort
of close I I spent time as a kid growing
up in Wales because I have a Welsh or
had a Welsh grandfather so we were
around lots of Irish people and so yeah
I love how an Irish person sounds have
you ever done an Irish accent
well are you trying to get me to do one
true yes I was yes I wanted them I'll
just throw a few words at you they're
really cliched but leprechaun
leprechaun
Blarney Stone
Pine of the good stuff oh give us a pint
of the good stuff true
and of course the luckiest of them all
the four leaf clover
four leaf clover do your day right I
mean of course you you probably didn't
even practice that like it's definitely
not
um I I tend to do accents all the time
for the girls yes um but if it comes to
a role I am terrified of doing accents
and I over prepare and I work with
dialect coaches is it something that
comes naturally to you do you study very
hard I have to work really really hard
people think that you can do it like
just Breeze in but no it takes hours and
hours and hours of work and yet you make
it look so effortless ah well thank you
I I find it sometimes it's a great tool
to get you closer to the story of the
character but
it doesn't get easier with practice
which is surprising to me okay speaking
of true stories I want to talk about the
Watcher which is coming out on Netflix
and it's based on a true story what can
you tell us
um yeah who is The Watcher it says it
all this beautiful family that live in
the um in New York City are wanting to
move out and live in a bigger house and
leafy green streets and
um they think they have their dream
moment with this home and it doesn't go
that way oh no dream no no no no it's
it's not only the scariest premise and
and and the most terrifying like
nightmare but it's a true story correct
well it's based on a true story that
means it's true
I I I I I I I can't handle how
terrifying this is and it's you know we
listen I we we work in in film and
television and you just don't want to
believe these things can really happen
and this one is seriously one of the
scariest things you'll ever watch and
it's so it's it looks so good thank you
I mean
well watch The Watcher because it comes
out October 13th and get ready to freak
out okay so you are like the queen of
skin care and um you have this amazing
uh new line that I've been playing with
called stripes and boy is it incredible
you shared this video look at this
but why do you look hot doing that
[Applause]
because I'm upside down
no that is not everyone looks good from
that angle oh let you know what I'm
gonna put that theory to the test
because we're going to get on a massage
table and Naomi's gonna do her skin care
regime and I gotta tell you there's a
very different point of view on your
skin care and I'm really excited to get
into it because it's also based in the
support of perimenopause and menopause
and as someone who is in the Dead Heat
of perimenopause I'm ready
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
not for the faint of heart and this is
why I wanted to do it
[Music]
foreign